The Soldier Who Voluntarily Became a Prisoner
in Auschwitz
Nazi troops invaded Poland on September 1,
1939, despite the best efforts of Captain
Witold Pilecki and his fellow Polish soldiers.
On November 9th of that same year, Witold
and Major Wlodarkiewicz founded the Tajna
Armia Polska (TAP or Polish Secret Army),
an underground organization that eventually
became consolidated with other resistance
forces into The Home Army.
Not long after the formation of organized
widespread Polish Resistance, its members
began hearing reports of the conditions within
the newly constructed Auschwitz Concentration
Camp put into operation in the Spring of 1940.
Those first reports originated with prisoners
released from the camp and from civilians
such as railroad employees and local residents.
In order to cut through the very troubling
rumors and figure out exactly what was going
on there, Pilecki came up with a bold plan-
become a prisoner at Auschwitz. With a little
convincing, his superiors eventually agreed
to allow him to go.
In order to help protect his wife and children
after he was captured, he took on the alias
Tomasz Serafinski, much to the chagrin of
the real Tomasz Serafinski who was thought
to be dead at the time (hence why his papers
and identity were chosen), but was not. Later,
the real Tomasz had some trouble because of
Pilecki using his papers and name (more on
this in the Bonus Facts below).
According to Eleonora Ostrowska, owner of
an apartment Pilecki was at when he was taken,
when a Nazi roundup began (lapanka, where
a city block would suddenly be closed off
and most of the civilians inside would be
rounded up and sent to slave labor camps and
sometimes even just mass-executed on the spot),
a member of the resistance came to help Pilecki
hide. Instead, Ostrowska said “Witold rejected
those opportunities and didn’t even try
to hide in my flat.” She reported that soon,
a German soldier knocked at the door and Pilecki
whispered to her “Report that I have fulfilled
the order,” and then opened the door and
was taken by the soldier along with about
2,000 other Poles in Warsaw on September 19,
1940.
It is important to note here that he didn’t
really know if he’d be sent to Auschwitz
at this point. As Dr. Daniel Paliwoda noted
of Pilecki’s capture, “Since the AB Aktion
and roundups were still going on, the Nazis
could have tortured and executed him in
occupied Warsaw’s Pawiak, Mokotów, or any
other Gestapo-run prison. They could have
taken him to Palmiry to murder him in the
forest. At the very least, they could have
sent him to a forced labor colony somewhere
in Germany.”
While he was willingly surrendering with the
hope of being sent to Auschwitz, Pilecki lamented
the behavior of his fellow countrymen during
the roundup. “What really annoyed me the
most was the passivity of this group of Poles.
All those picked up were already showing signs
of crowd psychology, the result being that
our whole crowd behaved like a herd of passive
sheep. A simple thought kept nagging me: stir
up everyone and get this mass of people moving.”
As he had hoped (perhaps the only person to
ever hope such a thing), he was sent to Auschwitz.
He later described his experience upon arrival:
Pilecki_ausch_f
We gave everything away into bags, to which
respective numbers were tied. Here our hair
of head and body were cut off, and we were
slightly sprinkled by cold water. I got a
blow in my jaw with a heavy rod. I spat out
my two teeth. Bleeding began. From that moment
we became mere numbers – I wore the number
4859…
We were struck over the head not only by SS
rifle butts, but by something far greater.
Our concepts of law and order and of what
was normal, all those ideas to which we had
become accustomed on this Earth, were given
a brutal kicking.
Pilecki also noted that one of the first indications
that he observed that Auschwitz was not just
a normal prison camp was the lack of food
given to prisoners; in his estimate, the rations
given to prisoners were “calculated in such
a way that people would live for six weeks.”
He also noted that a guard at the camp told
him, “Whoever will live longer — it means
he steals.”
Assessing the conditions inside Auschwitz
was only part of Pilecki’s mission. He also
took on responsibility for organizing a resistance
force within the camp, the Zwiazek Organizacji
Wojskowej (ZOW). The goals of ZOW included-
improving inmate morale, distributing any
extra food and clothing, setting up an intelligence
network within the camp, training prisoners
to eventually rise up against their guards
and liberate Auschwitz, and getting news in
and out of Auschwitz. Ensuring secrecy of
the ZOW led Pilecki to create cells within
the organization. He trusted the leaders of
each cell to withstand interrogation by the
guards, but even so each leader only knew
the names of the handful of people under his
command. This limited the risk to the entire
organization should an informant tip off a
guard or if a member was caught.
Pilecki’s first reports to the Polish government
and Allied forces left the camp with released
prisoners. But when releases became less common,
passing reports on to the outside world depended
largely on the success of prisoner escapes,
such as one that occurred on June 20, 1942
where four Poles managed to dress up as members
of the SS, weapons and all, and steal an SS
car which they boldly drove out of the main
gate of the camp.
A cobbled-together radio, built over the course
of seven months as parts could be acquired,
was used for a while in 1942 to transmit reports
until “one of our fellow’s big mouth”
resulted in the Nazis learning of the radio,
forcing the group to dismantle it before they
were caught red handed and executed.
Pilecki’s reports were the first to mention
the use of Zyklon B gas, a poisonous hydrogen
cyanide gas, and gas chambers used at the
camp. He saw the first use of Zyklon B gas
in early September 1941 when the Nazis used
it to kill 850 Soviet POWs and Poles in Block
11 of Auschwitz I. He also learned of the
gas chambers at Auschwitz II, or Auschwitz-Birkenau,
from other resistance members after construction
of the camp began in October 1941. ZOW also
managed to keep a pretty good running log
of roughly the number of inmates being brought
in to the camp and the estimated number of
deaths, noting at one point, “Over a thousand
a day from the new transports were gassed.
The corpses were burnt in the new crematoria.”
All of the reports were sent to the Polish
Government in Exile in London, and they in
turn forwarded the information to other Allied
forces. However, on the whole, the Allies
thought the reports of mass killings, starvation,
brutal and systemic torture, gas chambers,
medical experimentation, etc. were wildly
exaggerated and questioned the reliability
of Pilecki’s reports. (Note: During Pilecki’s
nearly three years there, several hundred
thousand people were killed at Auschwitz and,
beyond the death and horrific tortures, countless
others were experimented on in a variety of
ways by such individuals as the “Angel of
Death,” Dr. Josef Mengele. All total, it
is estimated that somewhere between 1 to 1.5
million people were killed at the camp.)
Significant doubt surrounding the accuracy
of his reports meant Pilecki’s plan to bring
about an uprising inside Auschwitz never came
to fruition. Pilecki had managed to convince
his network of resistance fighters inside
the camp that they could successfully take
control for a short while and escape if the
Allies and Polish Underground provided support.
He had envisioned airdrops of weapons and
possibly even Allied soldiers invading the
camp. However, the Allies never had any intention
of such an operation and the local Polish
resistance in Warsaw refused to attack due
to the large number of German troops stationed
nearby.
The Nazi guards began systematically eliminating
members of the ZOW resistance in 1943 and
so, with his reports being ignored, Pilecki
decided he needed to plead his case in person
for intervention in Auschwitz.
In April of 1943, he got his chance. After
handing over leadership of ZOW to his top
deputies, he and two others were assigned
the night shift at a bakery which was located
outside the camp’s perimeter fence. At an
opportune moment on the night of the 26th,
they managed to overpower a guard and cut
the phone lines. The three men then made a
run for it out of the back of the bakery.
As they ran, Pilecki stated, “Shots were
fired behind us. How fast we were running,
it is hard to describe. We were tearing the
air into rags by quick movements of our hands.”
It should be noted that anyone caught helping
an Auschwitz escapee would be killed along
with the escaped prisoner, something the local
populace knew well. Further, the 40 square
kilometers around Auschwitz were extremely
heavily patrolled and the escapees’ shaved
heads, tattered clothes, and gaunt appearance
would give them away in a second to anyone
who saw them. Despite this, all three not
only survived the initial escape, but managed
to get to safety without being recaptured.
Unfortunately, Pilecki’s plan to garner
support for liberating Auschwitz never materialized.
After arriving at the headquarters of the
Home Army on August 25, 1943 and desperately
pleading his case for the Home Army to put
all efforts into liberating Auschwitz, he
left feeling “bitter and disappointed”
when the idea was discarded as being too risky.
In his final report on Auschwitz, he further
vented his frustration on his superiors “cowardliness.”
After this, Pilecki continued to fight for
the Home Army, as well as trying to aid ZOW
in any way he could from the outside. He also
played a role in the Warsaw Uprising that
began in August of 1944, during which he was
captured by German troops in October of that
year and spent the rest of World War II as
a POW.
Witold Pilecki podczas sk³adania zeznañPilecki
wrote his final version of his report on Auschwitz
(later published in a book titled: The Auschwitz
Volunteer: Beyond Bravery) after the war while
spending time in Italy under the 2nd Polish
Corps before being ordered back to Poland
by General Wladyslaw Anders to gather intelligence
on communist activities in Poland. You see,
the invading Germans had been replaced by
another occupying power- the Soviet backed
Polish Committee of National Liberation. This
was a puppet provisional government setup
on July 22, 1944 in opposition to the Polish
Government in Exile, the latter of which was
supported by the majority of Polish people
and the West.
During his two years at this post, he managed
to, among many other things, gather documented
proof that the voting results of the People’s
Referendum of 1946 were heavily falsified
by the communists. Unfortunately, there was
little the Polish Government in Exile could
do. Even when his cover was blown in July
of 1946, Pilecki soldiered on and refused
to leave the country, continuing his work
collecting documented evidence of the many
atrocities against the Polish people being
committed by the Soviets and their puppet
government in Poland.
For this, he was ultimately arrested on May
7, 1947 by the Ministry of Public Security.
He was extensively tortured for many months
after, including having his fingernails ripped
off and ribs and nose broken. He later told
his wife of his life in this particular prison,
“Oświęcim [Auschwitz] compared with them
was just a trifle.”
Finally, he was given a show trial. When fellow
survivors of Auschwitz pled with then Prime
Minister of Poland, Józef Cyrankiewicz (himself
a survivor of Auschwitz and member of a resistance
in the prison), for the release of Pilecki,
instead he went the other way and wrote to
the judge, telling him to throw out record
of Pilecki’s time as a prisoner in Auschwitz.
This was a key piece of evidence in Pilecki’s
favor given one of the things he was being
accused of was being a German collaborator
during the war.
And so it was that as part of a crackdown
by the new Polish government against former
members of the Home Army resistance, Pilecki
was convicted of being a German collaborator
and a spy for the West, among many other charges,
ultimately sentenced to death via a gunshot
to his head. The sentence was carried out
on May 25, 1948 by Sergeant Piotr Smietanski,
“The Butcher of Mokotow Prison.” From
then on, mention of Pilecki’s name and numerous
heroic acts were censored in Poland, something
that wasn’t changed until 1989 when the
communist Polish government was overthrown.
Witold Pilecki’s last known words were reportedly,
“Long live free Poland.”
You might think it strange that Pilecki frequently,
quite willingly, threw himself into incredibly
dangerous situations despite the fact that
he had a wife and kids back home. Polish actor
Marek Probosz, who studied Pilecki extensively
before portraying him in The Death of Captain
Pilecki, stated of this, “Human beings were
the most precious thing for Pilecki, and especially
those who were oppressed. He would do anything
to liberate them, to help them.” Mirroring
this sentiment, Pilecki’s son, Andrzej later
said his father “would write that we should
live worthwhile lives, to respect others and
nature. He wrote to my sister to watch out
for every little ladybug, to not step on it
but place it instead on a leaf because everything
has been created for a reason. ‘Love nature.’
He instructed us like this in his letters.”
It wasn’t just his children he taught to
respect life at all levels. Two years after
Pilecki was executed, and at a time when his
family was struggling because of it, a man
approached Pilecki’s teenage son and stated,
“I was in prison [as a guard] with your
father. I want to help you because your father
was a saint.. Under his influence, I changed
my life. I do not harm anyone anymore.”
As mentioned, the real Tomasz Serafinski was
not dead, as Pilecki had thought when he took
his papers and assumed Tomasz’ identity
to be captured. After Pilecki’s escape from
Auschwitz, the real Tomasz was arrested on
December 25, 1943 for having escaped from
Auschwitz. He was then investigated for a
few weeks, including a fair amount of pretty
brutal strong arming, but was finally released
on January 14, 1944 when it was determined
he was not, in fact, the same individual who
had escaped from Auschwitz. Afterwards, Pilecki
and Tomasz actually became friends, and though
Pilecki was killed, according to Jacek Pawlowicz,
“That friendship is alive to this day, because
Andrzej Pilecki visits their family and is
very welcome there.”